if we were gonna disassemble a great
screenplay take it apart and examine it
what would we find
medicinal a great screenplay try to
reverse-engineer it and and construct
our own based on that what you would
find in it is various let's call them
techniques or tools that a screen writer
has used to keep the audience engaged so
that when you are when the curtain goes
up or you click the button and it says
streaming that that from that moment
there are they're manipulating your mind
your brain and using various tools and
techniques so that to keep you going for
a moment a moment and the the the first
book that I did the sequence approach oh
and see it this this this fine volume
what's actually I it sequences or in the
title and it's the how the organizing
principle of the book but I actually
thought sequences are kind of like the
hook to get the reader to learn about
all the other things techniques that you
can use to keep an audience interested
so it's like there hadn't been a book
explicitly about the sequence approach
before this and so I thought well that's
a good angle to use but there's once you
get the concept it's pretty simple to
understand but what goes on in the
sequences and what tools that filmmakers
use storytellers use to keep you
interested that's fascinating to me too
and so this was a I thought a good way
to get you interested so you can learn
and learn about these other things that
filmmakers do and so specifically the
kinds of things you'll find
let's let's start out at the beginning
what do you do there is a lot of thought
and work out there about three act
structure and the act structure etc etc
and in the very beginning of a movie you
can throw all that out it's not really
about that sort of thing it's really
about it tends to be about human
curiosity a can you come up with a
puzzle can you come up with some
interesting image or some line of
dialogue or something that is puzzling
this it leaves a gap in our
understanding and makes us wonder what
the answer is and people many times
account the common wisdom was you got a
hook an audience a reader in the first
10 pages of your screenplay
okay you got to hook them by the first
10 pages and I've always felt that
there's no reason why you can't hook
them on the first page all you have to
do is raise a question in the in the
readers mind on the first page and then
promise them an answer on page 2 yes
okay I'll turn the page
you know implicitly and you know you'll
get an answer and then on page 2 if you
get the answer but then there's maybe a
couple more questions raised and then
you want to find out and you keep
turning and then once you or you're in
there you're hooked so the readers
hooked so generally you'll see will
begin with some kind of puzzle something
that is intrigues us possibly the main
character but not always is involved in
that and then as the answers come you
can get a start to get to know a person
usually the classical formulation you
see oftentimes somebody struggling to
try to get something and then they get
it
we don't really know them yet but we
start to develop a sense of connection
with the character and that
if we're looking at a main character
hooked on the first part of the pay
introduced early in this film they're
not always that way but often then once
you're there then you're going to see
tools well I guess we can talk about
what I identify in the book as the four
main tools that filmmakers use in that
I've observed screenwriters and by
extension filmmakers the use in keeping
an audience engaged and the most obvious
one that you'll see goes by a couple
different names it's I call it
telegraphing which can be a negative
thing in acting and I supposed to
Telegraph your emotions that kind of
thing but it's a different sense of the
term telegraphing or it's also known as
advertising it's also known as in
theatre I've seen it called sign posts
or finger posts it's just simply telling
the audience what is coming a purely
narrative function and the thing to keep
in mind is that drama unlike a novel
drama is about something that hasn't
happened yet so it's particularly
obsessed with the future it's about
what's creating anticipation in the
audience a novel you've got a narrator
the narrator tells you something that
already happened before and you can rely
on the narrator to give you all the
information a play and a movie hasn't
happened yet
and that's why you'll see since the
beginning they are a stage play and a
screen play their instructions and
they're written in the present tense
this goes here this goes there this
person does that and then so that's
that's why you have that so that tense
because it's about it's a description
about something the audience is about to
see and how you do that how the
filmmakers or the actors are supposed to
do it so with that in mind telegraphing
is can be something as simple as a
character and what's called an
appointment the character says
I'll meet you at Jerry's juice eteri at
five o'clock okay so what does that mean
because film is selective we don't
generally start a camera and just keep
it running for an hour and a half you
cut to different places you like to keep
the audience oriented so if you tell the
audience two characters say I'm seeing
at Jerry's use of Terry at five o'clock
and we'll talk then then when you cut to
Jerry's you citerior you don't have to
explain why you're there you've already
anticipated it so a simple appointment
is an example of that a deadline has
more emotional Freight to it it's like
you have a certain number of hours to
get a certain thing done and so it can
put time pressure on a character but
else it also shapes the overall picture
picture too it can it can be used for
that for example there's a couple of
these that have deadlines 500 days of
summer comes along okay so it's
gradually counting up it skips around
but you know when you get to 500 yeah
the story's gonna be over Julie and
Julia I think it was called okay so what
was that they're gonna do the all the
recipes in the book one a day okay so
when you get 2 recipe 300 guess what you
know the movies probably gonna end
before and pretty soon so you're not
going to go on another hour or two and
then that helps shape an audience's
sense of where to invest its energy I
think we've all been in a situation
where we watch a movie we think it's
over and then it just keeps going I
thought it was done and then we're
sapped of energy and we're like how long
how much longer is this going on and
that just simply means that the
filmmaker has a storyteller hasn't
signaled to the audience properly when
the big moment is and sometimes you can
do that with simple telegraphing the
movie I'm trying to think of an American
Beauty it begins with a voice or a
disembodied voice saying in in a year
I'll be dead that's a deadline for you
you know so this is
give us a sense while work on this movie
will take place in over the course of a
year you know that implicitly okay so
that happened at the beginning of that
movie more typically telegraphing has
just used internally to keep us oriented
you have entice story the opening as
well very well-crafted movie where you
have the birthday parties coming so you
just have a sign that says birthday
happy birthday so we know what's about
to happen and then there's a reference
to we're moving in a week
okay so there's a deadline this movie
will take place in one week and it helps
or let's go to Pizza Planet these are
all examples within it so now we're
going there and there's another couple
scenes between that moment so that's
that's one tool that you will see in the
in movies that manage the tension and
keep you interested and keep you going
that one has purely narrative function
not really emotional one that has more
emotion is talked about this before it's
a term called dangling cause you have
cause and effect and this term applies
to a cause that doesn't have an effect
immediately
it dangles so it's instead of a
character saying instead of a boy likes
girl therefore boy kisses girl it's boy
likes girl and says I will kiss her you
know before the day is up and then
you'll have a bunch of scenes and but
you're waiting your pushes the audience
attention into the future well is it
going to happen or not so you'll have a
character give a warning to somebody a
warning a threat don't you dare come
back here if I see you here again I'm
gonna whatever a prediction an
expression of hope I just hope that that
this is that you know I'll survive today
or something like that or I'll learn
what I need to learn but a character
does that again that is something that
creates anticipation so you will tend in
a well-made movie to see that sort of
technique being used
the thing you don't want to have is the
audience wondering where is this going I
don't know where this is going or the
reader I've read ten pages I have no
idea what the story is well if you put
these little things in there embroider
the script with these elements these
tools then you're gonna help allay that
problem the next tool that you see is
dramatic irony this is a one where a
character knows the audience knows more
than one or more of the characters and
it has some salient that creates a
salient issue for the scene the
character doesn't know there's somebody
behind the wall wait with a gun to
shooting them you know so what are we
worried about why we in tune with that
because attuned to it because we want to
find out what happens when the character
figures it out this moment of
recognition oh my god or it could be
obviously a threat that creates suspense
it could be used for comic irony to
people that are talking and we don't
know that one of them is sleeping in the
other person's bed without them knowing
about it you know that every scene
there's a movie the shop around the
corner which was remade decades later as
you've got mail about two clerks the
first one was about two clerks working
in a shop who are each corresponding to
somebody that they have met yet that
they are in love with and they don't
realize that it's actually each other
and in person they can't stand each
other so every scene every scene that
has those two in it has an extra layer
of excitement to it and it leads us to
this anticipation what's gonna happen
when they find out the truth so that's
dramatic irony and then the fourth tool
is the one that gets all the press and
that you'll hear about relentlessly is
this idea of dramatic tension which is
where the three-act destruction comes in
and that's just character want something
we care about that character and we
in suspense about whether they're gonna
get it and that one you can sustain for
a whole feature film or longer and
you'll see it though in subunits you're
asking if you deconstruct it what are
you going to find in the screenplay well
you will tend to see one unifying
tension and the main tension that one
unifying tension will boy get girl will
girl get boy little girl get girl
whatever you know how you define it that
can be enough to that that creates the
the unity in a movie that makes it feel
like one movie rather than a whole bunch
of scenes stuck together it's like what
was that about well it was about whether
the person would get this okay that's
what it's about but within that within
the subunits you have these dramatic
scenes and dramatic scenes can use the
same structure a dramatic scene will
still have a character who wants
something and there's obstacles and if
you you know if you study acting you'll
see that it's drilled into the actors
what's my objective in the scene what am
I trying to do what is my action it's
not about emotion it's about trying to
do something drama drama comes from the
doing it's doing things it's action so
within each scene once you have a
connection to a character you will see
this same thing happening yes you have a
character who silver linings playbook
the character wants to reconnect with
his ex-wife okay that's the main
question main tension is he gonna do
that or not then within a scene he may
be fighting with his father about
whether he should you know go out for a
run or fix the the window that he broke
right that's a very different tension
but it's so attention and it's built in
within a particular scene
you'll also tend to see in successful
movies what the the sequences that are
they tend to be invisible to a viewer
but to a writer who is trying to create
a movie they're very useful building
blocks and that is seeing a note seeing
a mini movie a mini story within the
bigger one that is a component of it and
those also tend to have three act
structures then it's a nest instruction
you have multiple iterations at
different levels you have at the scene
level character one something there's
obstacles but the scenes are in service
of a bigger tension with character has
to go through multiple things to try to
get to what they want within the
sequence and then the sequences
themselves are built into the overall
three act structure of a dramatic piece
and and there are issues about how many
acts you have what are the acts should
they be four should there be none it's
it's really about how you define the
acts and whether you're playing with
dramatic tension if you have if you have
a a main issue about a character wanting
something and there's obstacles you have
to know who that character is you have
to connect with them emotionally you
have to know what the obstacles are yep
and then once you know those things
properly what's at stake then the
questions would raise the tension is out
there that's your end of your first act
if you don't know those things you're
not going to have any tension the
character wants something if there's two
characters you've let's say you're in a
park and you see two people playing
tennis and they're going at it they're
really going at it it's not necessarily
dramatic to you if they're strangers
it's just two people really going at it
and whether one wins or the other
doesn't mean anything but if you know
one of them and you know that person you
love them dearly and you found out that
they bet their entire fortune on this
one game and you also know that the guy
they're playing against or girl is a
hustler who who suckered them into it
then that changes your experience of it
you are now hanging on every shot and
you're hoping that somehow they're gonna
overcome this and though that
information that makes it dramatic
that's your first act you you can't have
an drama without that and then the third
act simply refers to the resolution of
that tension because you if you don't
have the third act that means you you
found out that you're your dearly
beloved brother that everything on this
game against the hustler and it's really
intense and then well I got to go and we
don't find out who wins it you could
probably do that you probably people
would get a little upset the audience
would feel incomplete so that's what
that three acts is so deconstructing it
those are the elements that that you
would find and these are the pieces that
are keeping us involved from one stage
from one moment in the story to the next
but the logins so if we took a not so
great or sort of a mediocre bland
screenplay we put it on the same table
and disassembled it we would see not
enough conflict and then we would see
maybe and this is like sort of a bad
word but emotional manipulation within
the story because you're saying that
these audience the audience the readers
they want these clues they don't want to
be given information right
well there's as I say there's many more
ways of being sick than there are being
healthy so if we if we read a script
that doesn't quite work for us then
obviously the issues are manifold what
kinds of mistakes we make there's a with
my like with my students not that my
students are brilliant and they hardly
ever make mistakes but let's just say
there's that outlier that makes a
mistake once in a while there's a
tendency
in no particular order the things that I
see and I see it in feature films - that
don't quite work
there is the tends to be a
misunderstanding of in the scheme that
I'm talking about what does it mean to
have the end of the second act you'll
see it there it's drummed into a lot of
them that this is the low point or some
kind of all this lost moment or you know
everything is hopeless and everything
has to get really really bad
and it's not necessarily so it depends
on what your story actually is the end
of the second act is where the question
is answered but the third act is really
it's resolved but preferably in a in a
way that is turns the story into
something deeper
it's me Lars Foreman said when I studied
with Mueller's form in Colombia days and
he put it this way he said in a in a
standard classic feature with drama the
audience's got to usually to
possibilities you know the person gets
it or they don't so let's say it's
hypothesis a or hypothesis B we hope for
hypothesis a we are afraid it's going to
be hypothesis B but the audience isn't
satisfied if the third act is either A
or B
it's got to be C it's got to be
something that transforms the way in
which we're aware of what the deeper
meaning to the story and that's what
really the function of the third act is
we we often feel like okay the main
character doesn't in the classic
formulation that I think most people go
by when they're trying to write a script
a character wants I'm going back to I
don't have sex on my mind but once the
girl let's just say it's easy let's say
all right a bank and they want to make
money let's say they want to get their
money back from someone who stole it
that
let's say that's it and they go all
through the movie once you know that you
know they take this various action to
try to get that objective then the idea
would be at the end of the second act it
doesn't look like they're ever gonna get
it okay oh it's impossible I all odds
are against them but in the third act
they managed to get it okay
that's that's a classical formulation
but there's other ways of seeing it that
it can be very powerful and and I try to
encourage my students to examine those
when they're looking when they're
looking at a story when they're coming
up with it what happens if they get it
at the end of the second act but isn't
what they thought it was or they paid a
price on it or the price was too big or
they did it but in the process damage
someone so deeply that now they have to
deal with the consequences of what they
did though those are ways of really
turning a story and examining the theme
and making it powerful like examples
from the book and the analyses that I do
are in Toy Story it's about this guy who
wants to maintain his position at the
top that's what it's about
and the question is a he maintains it or
gets it back or be he he never gets it
back that's how it's presented but at
the end of the second act what happens
well it isn't a question of that anymore
he gives up and recognizes that there's
he becomes selfless selfless and and
then the two team up the question isn't
answered A or B it becomes seem we're
going to accept whatever the outcome is
but we're gonna help each other so you
wind up with this really uplifting
ending in and you also when you do this
when you open yourself up to that
possibility it you can actually reverse
the tension in a way the typical feeling
is I love this character let's look at
the tennis court I love that character
and they're in deep trouble and I want
them to win but there are times when the
dr. want something you don't want them
to watch what you don't want them to get
and that tension is perfectly valid and
we we see like go back to classic the
apartment where the main character wants
to climb his way to the top that's not
what really weren't for him what we want
is for him to be a true human being
who's not degrading himself constantly
to get to the top we want him to be a
full human being who gets true love
that's what we want that's not what he
wants that's not what he's pursuing
through most of it so the end of the
second act he gets everything he could
possibly want and then I like it and now
we explore like the movie from a
different point of view you take the
premise and you flip it and that's
that's something that I have to work
with my students because there's an
automatic tendency to just go with the A
or B and an example of a movie that I
felt a movie that I've seen that I felt
could have used a rethinking of it was
the probably going to forget the name
again oh the REM the revenant came out a
few years ago okay so it's a root of
very simple revenge story this guy left
me for dead and lied about it and I'm
gonna just get that guy so what's the
tension he's either gonna get him or
incent and along the way you know we
have these sub scenes they're not all
against that guy none of them are
they're all about overcoming the
elements and the bad guys and being
helped by somebody in the winter weather
and the river that would have killed him
within 30 seconds but this is Hollywood
so it worked out okay and so it gets all
the way to the end now you're in a
position they notice the filmmakers
managed to put themselves in a position
where it was gonna be predictable it's
either gonna be the final fight is
either going to get the guy or he isn't
gonna get the guy and he's probably
gonna get the guy
and so inevitably in this kind of movie
where they have limited their options as
storytellers it's gonna come down to a
fight and the fight is gonna have a
moment where the bad guy almost kills
them maybe there's a knife but somehow
the good guy finds just enough at
reserve of energy where I came from we
don't know but somehow they're able us
throw them off and then get the upper
hand and they die a horrible horrible
death in this case he doesn't kill him
but he does pretty much the same thing -
it was done to him but look at that
story I mean I think what what are the
other options if you're if that story
comes to me and I'm looking at it
thinking well the main character is a
guy who wants revenge
is that even the most interesting
character this is what I would do with
this to turn this around what are these
other characters here well okay there's
the bad guy you could always see the bad
guys don't think they're the bad guy
they think they're doing it right
they're just living with the times were
going with the flow okay so this guy
leaves him for dead why does he leave
him for dead well he thinks that he's
gonna be a drag on the group and they're
all gonna die that's not a bad thing is
it that's a difficult question
now they painted the character is this
evil guy but there's another character
there the there's a army officer who's
leading them what if it's hit the men
are his responsibility and he almost
knows for certain if we keep this guy
then all my men could die now that's an
interesting problem and so he does
something questionable he leaves him for
dead or thinks he's dead and then he
finds out the guy's alive and that to me
is a more interesting dilemma and the
third act could be the confrontation
between them or it could be something
more interesting it's not just gonna be
a or b it's gonna be how do I redeem
myself how would I get this person to
understand I didn't do it
what what are the issues it becomes a
lot richer of a story and you can
probably still get a go a go in the
river you know the frozen river and you
could probably still have that stuff
but you'd not locked into something
that's just a or b so that's that's what
i see when you're talking about a script
it doesn't quite work a lot of good
things in it but but it kind of left
with okay well let's go home it doesn't
lead me away the thing in terms of story
development when I work with students
there is a this notion that occurred to
me it reminds me of a there's this old
Zen saying so we can be a little bit Zen
here just shortly sure at a time
but there's a saying that to a beginning
student the rivers are rivers and the
mountains and mountains right but to an
intermediate student the rivers are no
longer rivers amounts are no longer
mountains to an advanced student though
guess what you know the rivers are
rivers again in the mountains amounts
well I I see this you can probably
google that and I'm sure you'll find it
under Zen sayings about mountains but to
a beginning screenwriting student you
want to write a script just start
writing a script okay write the scenes
okay I got this okay I'm gonna start
writing and if you put a bunch of scenes
together you'll have a script you'll
have a story an intermediate student
learns no no you have to plan the story
first you've got to know what what is
the story how do you know what scenes
you're gonna have unless you have a the
story that tells you and I've run into
this I've when I read an unsolicited
script very often I start with a lot of
notes which are pertaining to the
moments the scenes and then I realized
after few pages in wait a minute I don't
even know if the story needs those
scenes
I gotta find figure out what the story
is because then I'm wasting my time
writing detailed notes on scenes that I
should be thrown out because you don't
need it or they're not optimal for the
story so that's that's the intermediate
student but when you get to the advanced
level you realize that again going back
to constructivist psychology characters
audiences don't actually see stories at
all they don't
what do they say they see scenes okay
they see scenes and in the process of
watching the scenes they construct a
story in their minds I put the scenes
together and they understand there's a
story but the story is not materially
present ever it's always just
constructed in our heads and therefore
since all you see are scenes when you
have a premise the way you want to
develop it is the way that maximizes
them the amount of really cool scenes in
it that I've see sometimes see students
well here's a story and I have to stick
with it but the way you've developed the
story you're not allowing for any really
interesting scenes I've seen those
scenes I've seen the ones in revenue you
know I've seen in variations I've seen
that fight before but maybe you could
turn the story in a way that yeah that's
gonna be a really cool scene and how
about that one you you don't you realize
if you withhold the information here
from the character now you've got a
scene that has a double meaning to it
there's a scene in a script that I've
consulted on and did a rewrite on and
and there was a the father is finds the
daughter with a lover he shouldn't she
shouldn't be with and it's like yo how
could you do that it's like what father
I hate you no it's exactly the kind of
scene you'd see ever anytime anywhere
but my but the way every did it was that
the lovers are together and and they see
the father coming and the daughter hides
and the father sees the guy and he's
really in a tough mood he's struggling
with his career and he sits down with
the guy with the daughter right there
and he's talking about his relationship
with his daughter and how he doesn't
understand her and he wants a you know
everything is really rich now yeah cuz
we know that the daughter is hiding
there and and that's a really cool scene
let's do that seeing let's put that
scene in rather than one that we've seen
a million times and it's all it come it
can come down to how you choose to
develop it so the scripts that don't
quite work I've seen that pattern with
the third act I've seen choices made in
terms of developing them that don't fit
that don't maximize the possibilities
that are present there there there's the
question of which we have not talked
about of dialogue what dialogue is
okay so here there's an interesting
problem that you do see with with
scripts that maybe don't work that well
is they have talked but no dialogue talk
speed human speech can be poetic it can
be witty clever polite uh moving but it
isn't dialogue unless there's there's
action under it and that's that's
something to look for there's really two
elements of a dialogue that you can
learn about it isn't it isn't simply a
talent some people have a natural talent
they can ear for it and they capture it
but it goes beyond that you can actually
learn how to do this and buy action well
let me explain it this way in a dramatic
scene you'll often find not a dramatic
scene in the scene the problem is no
drama the students will come with cue in
it what I call cue a dialogue how are
you today okay how about you we're not
bad I think I'll go to the store what
about you I think I'll not go to the
store you know what that's that's cue a
dialogue now and it's it doesn't really
qualify as dialogue it's useful to think
of dialogue especially in the rewrite
stage and I'd emphasize that in the
first draft pour it on the page and
don't worry if it's Q&A dialogue don't
worry about it
it'll only block you up if you worry
about it but once it's on the page and
you're thinking if it's working but
everybody loves it you say we're done if
it isn't working there are some
diagnostic tools you can use to study
your dialogue and see what you can do
with it
there is this concept of subtext and
dialogue and I'll have to give you a
warning that I use the term in a way
different from pretty much everybody
else I've seen that used like in the
McKee book he talks about subtext and
dialogue and there's a there's a passage
and mary says well let's say you have
two lovers and there
at a table and it's beautiful and you
know of candle lit and one says to the
other darling I love you I love you I
love you and he says well that's not
octuple because it's two of them knows
what I'm gonna style and he says well
that really needs to be subtext you need
subtext and it'd be better if you give
them an action and he's example of a a
couple that's repairing and a flat tire
and we get from that action that they're
in love but they don't ever say it okay
so I mean I look at that I think I have
a feeling I've been in that situation
where I've been with some of and I said
I spoke to him and it was active all so
they did it why isn't it active oh well
that version of subtext what it means
I've never found very helpful I get the
idea okay you want to say things without
saying it otherwise it's too on-the-nose
but I think it's more useful to think of
subtext as the underlying format what am
i doing what am i doing in the scene and
actors asked what am i doing
and dialogue is action with words that's
all it is it's somebody doing something
but they're using words instead of
actions physical actions and so it's a
useful thing when you have a scene
that's already written to just see
whether you can reduce each line of
dialogue to a verb and the kind of verbs
you're looking for are things like
attack defend deflect
persuade seduce those are the kinds of
verbs you want the the lines to have
okay
you don't want explain it's just
emotionally neutral and that's where the
Q&A thing comes in so if you have the
dialogue how are you today and the
person says well I didn't sleep much
last night
that's Q&A but if you have a character
who says you look like hell and they say
well I didn't sleep much last night you
see now you've got attack defense hey I
didn't sleep much so you transform it
into something that's actually moves
that actually is dynamic and we're
following action and that's that's the
other thing if you want to know what
people what cynics agree
play that works that gets people going
one other element is that people follow
action which is somebody doing something
or something doing something and even in
your description you keep that in mind
that in a stage play you're gonna list
all this stuff that's on the stage but
in a movie you want a character to walk
through a room and pass by a you know
fancy couch with a cat on it and move to
and pick up a you know you want it to be
all contained within action because
people watch that
so that's subtext I think it's useful
way of thinking of subtext it's what's
the action what's the verb that's
underlying it and that's you can stray
from that a little bit but most of the
time you want that to be the case you
won't be able to identify what is the
person doing the question of on-the-nose
dialogue is not related to subtext I'm
the newest dialogue is defined as
characters say exactly what they are
thinking and it's straightforward and
it's boring so in that example okay man
says to the woman I love you I love you
I love you and okay so that is that's a
bit on the nose let's say but the the
way to attack that again is in the
rewrite stage not when you're trying to
come up with it is there are simple
there are literary devices that are
ancient that you can employ then the
easiest one is irony you take a
character who says you look like hell
okay that's a straightforward attack and
says you look beautiful
just flip it completely upside down and
they'll be like what do you mean I
couldn't sleep last night you know if
they'll be defend themselves cuz they're
gonna get it there's a lot of human
interaction is ironic and there's we
talked about in the other book the
science of screenwriting that there's
there are theories that human beings in
order to function as a society need to
have plausible deniability you need to
test things out around an explosive
issue like sex I mean what if you're
interested in somebody but you're not
sure you should ask them
out because maybe there's a problem so
you could go up to them and tell them a
story about there was this guy I know
and he was in love with this girl but
she was already involved with somebody
and you know and the other the target of
the seduction may know exactly they're
talking about her but if the person says
I'm married it says mom and saying you
know I'm just telling a story see but so
you have irony irony is basically saying
two opposite things at the same time and
like it's it's pouring rain I love this
weather and people get it or nice shoes
you got there and people people ago
what's wrong with them you know they're
gonna understand it it's in the tone and
the way you do it but it's like I didn't
say anything I just said they're nice
shoes that's all um so irony is a useful
one and there's trouble in paradise
again a great movie that everybody
should watch but there is a scene where
there's two guys that are rivals for the
same woman and one of them goofed up and
you know he lost something that belonged
to her on a date and so the other guy's
riding him so what do they they they
they meet each other in the in a shop
where they're you can buy another one of
what she was a person then the guy comes
in he says oh how are you doing major
does mmm you know and then he says
you're looking fine major he said I've
had enough of your insulting remarks and
write it it works really well
okay so irony is one then another one is
metaphor that you'll see people speaking
and people do this a lot so instead of
subtext I think a preferred term would
be indirection it's indirect speech or
sometimes you could call it conflicted
speech speech that's rich because it has
double meanings and a great example that
I like from the Double Indemnity
picture
it's a very famous scene in which a man
is interested in a married woman and he
said all he says is when she says my
husband don't be back at 8 o'clock he
says he implies I don't want to see him
anymore or see you and she says there's
a speed limit in this state mr. net
forty-five miles an hour and he says how
fast was I going officer she says I'd
say about 90 why'd you get off your
motorcycle give me a ticket suppose I'll
let you off with a warning this time
you know the whole thing is carried on
indirectly through metaphor and that is
a powerful way of doing it plus he can
say hey I was just talking about traffic
I was talking about we need to get I
wasn't going after your wife it's fine
so that's part of the reason you have it
but also having it in your script makes
it richer makes it like wow this is
really pop and powerful and that's the
other thing to keep in mind about a
screenplay as opposed to a novel is it's
a limited amount of time so it has to be
richer everything they say a novel is
drama
a novel is gossip drama is scandal you
know everybody is instead of walking
you're running so if you have dialog
it's precious and you want it to be rich
so indirection can help another one is
and by the way in the social network is
a great study if you want to look at how
dialogue is done with indirection he
uses irony in an awful lot and a
character saying I'm heartbroken about
that and you know that he's just
bullshitting them or somebody saying oh
this is really classy you know the but
said indirectly I've let me let the
classiness waft over me one character
says and it's clear he's mean it's not
or another one is cease and desist
letter you know I guess that cease and
desist letter really scared the out
of him when he means it didn't have any
effect all he did all of the circuits
that did was flip them into irony but he
also uses metaphor okay well if these
two characters want to stand on my
shoulders and pretend they're tall
that's fine well they're not they're
they're big they're not going to
but he's usually metaphor right metonymy
if something stands for something else
again going back to the social network
it's he tells a story about the founder
of the founder of Victoria's Secret who
sold out too soon he could have made 500
million he only made 5 million
so he threw himself off the Golden Gate
Bridge right that's a story that's told
and then he tells Mark Zuckerberg
character you know you don't want to
sell it too soon because the waters of
the Golden Gate are very cold he doesn't
have to say that it's that you're gonna
regret this that's on the nose dialogue
ends don't sell out too soon because
you're gonna regret this if you say that
the waters under are cold then that's a
much more powerful way of doing it and
that's metonymy is something standing
for for something else in the class of
things you know the bridge stands for
suicide or depression or failure so
that's that's what you can do to make
dialog not on the nose and I would say
subtext you want in every line if you
can in direction is more like spice you
add it as needed and look for
opportunities but people don't use it
all the time so you don't need to use it
all the time well even in sharp objects
where Amy Adams goes back to the little
town that she was raised and she doesn't
really want to be there and she says in
the beginning you know when they say you
know bless your heart that doesn't mean
what it means it basically means the
opposite right and that's what's so
great about the show too is a lot of
stuff is caged in this sweetness right
but it doesn't mean it in fact it is
with I think your name is Eudora the
fantastic character played by Patricia
Clarkson Patricia Clarkson is the mother
and she is so skilled at that that kind
of dialogue where a lot of stuff is said
to kind of take the power away from
different characters and it's done so
well yeah well there's a movie I
recently saw recently again going back a
little further it's called bad day at
Black Rock with Ben Sir Tracy and it's
not a Western it
set in Arizona but it's not a Western
and it involves a guy showing up in this
small town where people nobody's been
the Train has not stopped in the last
three years and it's something that's
off this guy usually goes right on
through nobody comes to Black Rock
anymore and everybody's acting real
suspicious who is this guy what does he
want
and they he's trying to get information
to go find somebody and the moment they
mentioned the name it's like nobody
wants to help him so the dialog is very
functional the indirect dialog is very
functional because he can't say okay did
somebody murder them
what happened did somebody murder him
what what's going on here he's got to
ask questions and they don't want to
give him a lot of answers so it's all
this maneuverable maneuvering and it's a
sight to behold how they pulled that off
it's worth it's exciting movie but it's
also worth looking at just for the the
way in direction is used asking
questions without asking them answering
them giving warnings to people without
warning them that kind of thing so it
makes for rich screenwriting so that
would be another element if the dialogue
is has power to it I mean the power in
the sense of action and is not all on
the nose that it uses in direction and
the subtleties the way humans actually
do talk then it's gonna be more
successful and that's a it just takes
practice and it just takes rewriting
that's all it's not it's not that hard
to do actually especially irony just
look at look at your stuff and see what
happens if the character says the
opposite and and find out
so I was watching a video the other day
and it was from an art professor and he
was talking about how good artists tend
to be bad students and he talked about
how really the I mean the ones that sit
in the front row that are super smart
and raised their hand he says may not be
the best artist the one it's the one in
the back with the hangover and the
tortured love affair that kind of has
his head down that's actually really
gonna be fantastic I was wondering if
the same is true for writers well I
wouldn't recommend having a hangover
okay funny young people are listening
don't abuse up medicated or a tortured
love affair right don't ya tortured love
affair a couple okay yeah get a cup
under your belt and yeah yeah go easy on
them but the type of student what's
interesting about that I guess in terms
of screenwriting in terms of the
students I've had I've had that I've had
the gamut I've had the ones who are on
time with their assignments while I sit
around a table so I don't know if
they're in the front row I mean they're
kind of with the farm and and they turn
in their work and really apply
themselves and learn and they can be you
know Fulbright Scholars or something and
then I've had the ones that are quirky
and wind up surprising you with what
where did that come from I think the the
key for a sexual successful artist maybe
maybe where that comes from and I don't
know what that person was talking about
but exactly but people who take risks
tend to not be 4.0 students because you
could fail in other words if you're
really focused on that then you try to
be risk-averse and okay I know I know
somebody who wanted a 4.0 in college
because they wanted to get into med
school it's hard to get into med school
so he did what he could
well this guy was like he was a myth he
was a major in the
sex like which is a hard Greek and Latin
but he was Greek so he knew Greek so it
wasn't a hard thing it was something
that was gonna be giving him a good
grade without a risk of failing I mean I
took ancient Greek and it was not pretty
okay but this person was actually
playing it safe and then they were
making sure all the courses were there
was gonna be organic chemistry that's
gonna be hard but while I'm doing that
I'm gonna do a bunch of same things and
then 4.0 so that may be the case I'm an
artist or a creative person is gonna
tend to resist rigidity they're gonna
probably challenge things they're gonna
follow a unique path they're gonna
describe the world the way they see it
the way they experience it and it's not
going to conform to a pattern of grading
it's gonna conform to it's it's gonna
the question will be whether it if
there's a way of connecting it's
connecting with an audience so that's
that's what I've seen with that it's
really important to to trust and be
willing to give it you know give it a
shot try something you're not used to
expose something you're not comfortable
with maybe that may be where all the
power is you can see students that might
write an action movie in a superhero
movie and then the one time they write
something that it's about their you know
400-pound cousin who who steals people's
ATM card scams UM's oh he can buy
munchies that's interesting you know or
the the father who absentee father who
finally treated his daughter to a great
day on her birthday and then found out
he chars everything to her now that's
whoa you know okay that's not that
that's unique and interesting I don't
want to see that in fact in the
exercises we do in our introductory
class one thing that I have the students
do is write character profiles of people
they know without telling them well how
they're gonna be used I say who's the
biggest liar you know
write a one-page description that's
gonna help me understand what they're
like the most ambitious person you know
the the most religious that you know the
most the most conceited that kind of
thing and then when when they bring them
and then they the more unique if they
write a generic one you can tell if
they're talking about someone they know
then it gets very specific they have a
real sense of the person then you take
that person okay how about what if they
were put in this situation what would
they do and you wind up with an
interesting story so is that a I think a
studious dedicated student could do that
as well as somebody who's got a hangover
it's it's a matter of being open to
digging down and finding out the truth
about how how you experience things and
then bringing it to bear the story I
bring it to bear in story form
connecting to an audience well I'm just
following up with that then he also said
that within each group of artists it's
like a gang mentality in some sense and
there's this unspoken rule about who the
Alpha is no one needs to identify and we
everybody knows too that alpha is but
then with the scapegoat in the group
there's like this outlier sort of thing
that comes out of that one scapegoat so
we kind of know who the Alpha is we know
who the beta is we might know below that
but there's this one scapegoated
character and that one sometimes can be
the sort of shocking revelatory artist
oh the one that everybody rejects right
in kind of poo-poos and doesn't have the
same credentials maybe and then some
like magical thing comes out of that I
don't know interesting
well I again I don't know what field of
art that was exactly but art visual arts
let's say there's a the difference is
that screen writers have a mass audience
that they're trying to connect with and
the visual arts don't have that as much
anymore
so the tendency I think there tends to
be on focusing on expression how do you
express this and who's really good at
expressing it and who can be outrageous
as you say that kind of thing and then
in that sense you might have a focus on
the creators like a gang of people that
are one of them is the Alpha that's
because they're all working on their
expression and this guy expressing this
is really powerful your girls and this
one does I'm just speculating
whereas this in screenwriting it's
really about what that person does if
they're if they're like capturing scenes
really vividly ok I don't want to follow
them but I want to find out how they're
doing that because then I want to do it
I had a fellow student at when I was in
grad school who just she lived the biker
life I mean she had been immersed in it
and man the kinds of scenes she wrote it
wasn't just that it was so authentic but
the way she had the dialogue and the
scenes was just like you were there so
it was like I wouldn't consider her a
gang leader or anything you were part of
a gang you have friends but it was I
gotta see I gotta sit down and sit in a
bar and listen to people and see whether
I can capture the kind of ambience and
she's doing and try to learn from her so
so offhand I don't maybe I'm not a much
involved in the students lives but I
don't see them in that way forming that
kind of what you're describing as far as
screenwriting professionals you know
again there's it's I don't know how much
there are certain influences that
happened and but it's pretty much
whatever you can do to apply your craft
to get the next job is what counts as
opposed to well let me put it this way
too that screenwriting is the
unproductive not the screenplay that's a
little different
you know it's changing it hopefully but
when you're a visual artist you're doing
it there it is you're not describing on
paper something you'd like to do and
everybody's sitting around talking about
the things that they've they're
describing it's everybody comparing
their artwork whereas the screenwriter
is they're gonna try to get the whether
it's successful is a matter of sales and
recognition and and it's out there it's
not among peers that sort of thing now
by changing if we get to the point where
more writers are generating their own
material and making things because
production and distribution has changed
then maybe you'll see that and certainly
among bunch of filmmakers getting
together who does what and they would
then they would be closer to the artists
experience than the virtual artists but
the potential artists were we have our
story here just give me a few million
dollars and we'll turn it into a feature
film if we can go beyond that then it
could be more like that so we'll talk in
10 years we'll see where it is then
we'll get back to and we'll find out if
the gangs are there in the screenwriting
can you give me an example of an
unreliable narrator what is that I'm
reliable narrator what would be can you
give me example of a movie that had that
I'm trying to think well here people
used that a lot and I was just curious
how is that different from a reliable
narrator so let's suppose we think take
Kevin Spacey's voiceover and American
Beauty right so I would say that would
be a reliable narrator wouldn't it
because he's talking about his own life
right but an unreliable narrator I'm
I've heard the term bandied around and I
was curious well I've seen it in fiction
I'd have to think about movies okay
fiction Dan unreliable narrator the
example that I read recently would be a
book called The Things They Carried by
Tim O'Brien
and this is one in which it's a story
about a platoon or a squad of soldiers
in Vietnam but the narrator is it's told
in the first person as I recall but let
me think about that I'm not sure that
not sure it's in the first person
but the narrator is describing these
events very vividly but sometimes he
changes what happened in a later chapter
or he'll reflect on the meaning of
storytelling in you know kind of meta in
that way the narrator will say that's
what happened but but you can't always
tell them war whether a war story is
real or not and then he'll describe it a
slightly different way or a bunch of
different ways you might think about it
and he even talked to see as a
digression about how to tell a real war
story from from a fake one if it
elevates you if it makes you inspired
it's a lie if it's if it has if it's an
obscenity that has no redeeming quality
that's a real story if that's what
really happened so that's an example in
a in a novel in terms of a screenplay I
I guess I would have to see an example
of it yes I've heard of that it's not
something that I
dealin particularly so it's for fiction
right maybe I'm mistaken then because it
sounds like it's just fiction I'm sure
it's been attempted in cinema yeah
maybe there's a movie called blow up
yeah I don't
from the 60s like 1966 and I think if
you looked at a literary critique of it
that might be one that's considered to
have an unreliable narrator because
we're not really certain whether a
murder happened or not and so what what
did we just see exactly I mean probably
as soon as the interviews I don't think
of maybe another example but I think
because cinema is so rigorously real I
mean it relies on mechanical
reproduction of life if something that
were shown we're assuming it's happening
and if it isn't or if it turns out that
didn't happen that may be a very
frustrating experience for the audience
because I've invested in this and now
I'm not sure what that was so you know
I'm not a lot of help on that one but I
I'll research it and get okay that's not
good do you think it's misleading or
selling false hope to have screenwriting
books to teach courses to give people
the idea that they can actually make a
living as a screenwriter it depends on
how it's sold there's okay I'll give you
an example a few years ago maybe a
decade ago now on Chapman's own website
they had a very clever kind of marketing
thing and it was a clapboard you know
and it said on it
you're it said like a student's name and
then the feature film was your movie
career you know and and I looked at that
and I contacted Dean you have to take
that down you're saying that people will
get a career out of this
that's like you can't say that you can't
sell this school on that idea because
it's so difficult
you have to yes you're going to try to
nurture them you're going to try to help
them be the best filmmakers they can be
but to say to have like a warranty that
yeah at the end of this you know you'll
have a job is not something that that's
ethical the question of the function of
the books and the function of the of the
film school actually I thought I'll
quote somebody I thought just online
recently Martin Scorsese saying if you
if you want to pursue film because you
think you'd like a career in it then
don't do it if you want to pursue film
because you you will always be making
films and you can't stop it then do it
and that's how I see it i we have
students that come in what was it
I used to tell the and the prospective
students I don't know if I've ever got
in trouble for it but I would tell them
no I would tell them they're all eager
and they they're thinking they're going
to go to films God say if you can do
anything else and be happy do it then
before they got accepted before they
applied if you can do anything else
because this is gonna be really really
hard and you'll have doubts and
most people don't have a career in it
but if you have that fire inside you
have the other point of view which is at
some point well let me tell you a
personal story when when my my first
wife was was passing away she was in
hospice okay and in the same room there
was somebody who I couldn't tell if it
was a man or woman it was this figure
very ancient kind of like that if it was
time for a bath the people came in gave
bath if TV was on all day I don't know
whether anybody was what actually
watching it and I I thought I looked at
that they said you that's a reality
that's gonna be you someday and when
you're in that position where you can't
take a bath without somebody giving it
to you and you haven't really given it a
shot like do something that's really
exciting you haven't done that you're
not even gonna be able to go like that
you're gonna have to ask the nurse to do
that and you that's the reality
there's wanting to do this thing and the
fact that you're gonna be in that place
and we're all gonna be there well what
do you want it to be when you look back
and so if you don't do it and a lot of
people actually they come out and then
they find a niche somewhere else in the
business they don't have a movie made
and some will find it very interesting
but we have a really brilliant writer
graduated a few years ago was a double
major and got a great scholarship to
study psychology as a grad student and
his brilliant and that's the direction
she went she knows an inside sense of
what it's like to tell a story
see a movie and never see a movie the
same again once you've studied it but
she took a different path so I don't
think it was a waste for her she was
actually really good so the question of
the ethics of it I think if people are
interested in it they're going to avail
themselves of whatever they can and it's
up to them to try to see what's possible
in their life if you yeah but if you
were to sell a product and say this will
get you in this will be your ticket this
is a way to do it then that's more on
the edge you don't want to raise
people's hopes like that you want to be
honest with them
and and we live you know at a at a time
like I say that the technology and
distribution has changed you may wind up
making movies they may just be smaller
they may be you don't make a living at
it you do something else but you were
still making movies and you do it all
your life I know one person have
collaborated with who's about 81 years
old and he had a very successful career
as a director and a producer but he's 81
and when you're 81 everybody you know is
dead you know or they're not in the
business anymore but he's out there
working with students he's working with
you know he works in the the Ruskin
Theatre directing even he just wants to
this guy will do it until he can't do it
anymore
and it doesn't matter if he gets paid or
not they'd love to be paid but he wants
to be on a set with actors working with
them creating magic for an audience
that's in him to his blood that's what
he's gonna do so did you ever personally
experience naysayers naysayers meaning
well people that tried to persuade you
to do something else or or told you
flat-out you'll never do this you'll
never even even you know yeah hello
screenplay whatever did you encounter
that and right well I had this
experience once of well you you get a
lot of it you know when you're when
you're a potential writer it's supposed
to a writer but actually once you're
writing your writing forget it that's it
but you might have the impression and I
did okay well I'm have potential here
but it's not realized I'm gonna maybe it
won't happen and then you have friends
that are going on and having families
and doing stuff and I remember one time
I had it like I say I think Frank
Danielle was this remarkable teacher
well I helped me write the thesis
screenplay but then a few years out of
school you know and I was trying to do a
follow-up that one had gotten me an
agent and got me recognition and maybe
gets made my career started but I found
that in without his guidance the
follow-up script was really hard and I
was struggling and then I said well
get into playwriting where I'll have an
audience and get my spark back and I
went to this theater this writing class
in a play in New York theater in New
York City and came home one day just so
frustrated and I I had decided that's it
I'm gonna do this anymore
wouldn't do something else that's it and
this voice in my head said I wonder if
there's a story in this I wonder if I
could turn this into a story okay
somebody who's so dead they're gonna
give up and that's when I realize it's
never gonna go away it's gonna it's just
part of you and it's you're gonna do
this and I turn that into a play that
won me the first prize I wanted in for
writing I'm one of my first hundred
dollars in San Francisco it was done up
in San Francisco but so that that's
sitting maybe an example of naysayers
but certainly people don't don't get it
or but it's it's about what you want to
do with the bulk of your waking hours is
that something that excites you so and
also the flip side of that is on a
Tuesdays with Maurey did you where it's
him advising Mitch Albom not to chase
success and to stop and sort of see the
life around him so there's there's that
as well at home
all right of smelling the roses kind of
thing because I've heard of that but
I've not read that oh it's great yeah
that's great you can also go on and see
there it's based on a real guy
I think Morrie Schwartz this was named
yeah and so he's fantastic in these
interviews and you know it's a very
touching story and I think Mitch is
still writing and well that's it's true
you you have this idea of nostalgia and
most people think I think of nostalgia
as seeing the past wrongly you don't see
it properly because it's rose-colored
glasses or it's it's an idealized
version of your past but it occurred to
me a few years ago what massage really
is it's experiencing moments in your
past stripped of any anxiety for the
future because when you're in that
situation when you're let me and I think
about it in New York City you're sitting
among friends at a
fading eclairs and having coffee and
talking about stories and it's like
you're 25 years old and you have all
this and what could be better and you
stay there until they the guy throws you
how you got on get another Eclair we're
gonna get out of here because we gotta
have this table and it but at the time
you're worried about well it's just a
waste of time am I doing this right am i
maybe this is all foolish so it's harder
to experience that joy so this key to
living of course is to experience every
day as nostalgia like stripped of this
anxiety but that maybe is what what he's
talking about that you you have these
moments and those moments are or you're
actually living this is you're you're
actually doing it you're not about to do
it and you're not striving to do it
you're doing it right now and that's
what you do so yeah passive versus
active main character mmm-hmm what's
okay passive versus this is an
opportunity situation because most
people assume and most movies are about
somebody who's active and they got to do
something but there are successful
pictures where you have someone who's
not and how do those work that's that's
what you look for you say well everybody
says do this and this one doesn't but it
still works so why well what they do
that that compensate it for it because
obviously if you have an active main
character it's easy to watch you're
gonna see whether they get what they
want or not and it's all taken care of
but what about that well what you'll see
is there still has to be conflict as
long as there's conflict you'll be okay
because the conflict will will create
the suspense and the tension that
sustains us if you're using dramatic
tension has it main tool not all movies
do there are like ensemble pieces that
will be following a bunch of different
stories of different characters and the
unifying element is Amelia like diner
it's about a diner it's what happens in
a diner and as long as it's understood
by the audience that that's what they're
watching you know you can signal that
that's what it's about in fact that
movie it was a 1982 picture
I believe the opening title is like a
week before Christmas 1959 or something
like that maybe 1958 and then it's about
the Baltimore Colts and all this stuff
but it gives you a sense right away from
the opening it's gonna take place in
about a week okay I think it actually
starts Christmas Eve and it's gonna take
it takes place in a week okay so that
frames it and then you have an ensemble
people and they're there's dramatic
conflicts within those but the overall
picture doesn't and have doesn't utilize
dramatic tension as it's the main tool
so you don't have that you have first
acts of all the different characters and
the different subplots and each subplot
has its own act structure generally
there are a couple that kind of dangle
off and disappear but most of them the
main ones do but if we go back to the
main the most common form which is
character with an objective and there's
obstacles the an active one helps but
there was a famous editor I was told
about and I don't remember who it was
who said the secret to the craft is that
all scenes are either chases or escapes
do you for somebody trying to get
something or trying to avoid something
and a passive character can be somebody
who's just trying to avoid something and
the key is to build a circumstance where
that's hard like the Lars and the real
girl talked about that this is a movie
where the you have a passive main
character he's just wants to all he
wants to do it's an escape story because
the whole town is united to try to not
let him do what he wants to do by the
very indirect means playing along with
them but you can see the tension is
there as that surrounds the question is
is he ever going to get better so there
that would being a passive main
character or I like Cuckoo's Nest what
does this guy want to do he wants to
avoid doing work he wants to play cards
doesn't have any agenda beyond that but
the way the story is constructed he's
placed in the worst possible situation
for his unique characteristics which is
that he's he's a noble person who wants
to help people you know but he has an
opportunity he's and and
this world crushes them so that that's
something you can look for a graduate I
think sorry the Graduate is right
he doesn't have to pursue her I do have
an analysis of the Graduate in the book
he doesn't have to pursue her she's in
his laughs nothing there but it what
keeps us suspended there is actually
that's not an escape movie it's dramatic
irony so you look at the middle part of
that this example of a movie where the
second act is actually not that long
it's about equal size with the first and
third acts the second act is about will
he get caught and you have combat guy
earn a comic irony played with where and
sometimes dramatic irony where the
mother inquires we'd go every night he
you know he cuts himself while shaving
you can see he's not comfortable and so
you know I just drive or in the hotel
where everybody recognizes him he's with
the girl and the Katharine Ross the
actress she's with me later
oh yeah and at the hotel where he's been
having these liaisons and everybody
knows him and he's trying to conceal
from her what what was happening so
that's one the Sunset Boulevard is a
movie about a guy who's trying to hustle
this older woman
he's writer he's trying to hustle her
and after a certain point really from
the mid middle of the movie on he's he's
very passive he's he's just yeah it's
kind of avoiding the world so but that's
it's an escape and that way he's trying
to just stay away from everything and
the world intrudes but largely that one
is sustained by a little bit of tension
about someone trying to not let him
escape and voiceover narration which
keeps us it's a form of telegraphing you
know this is about to happen or little
did I know this would happen that kind
of thing so that we're anticipating so
that's that so the answer the question
can you have a passive main character
will look for where the conflicts are
if the character is passive never wants
to do anything can you put them in a
situation that challenges that and makes
them fight
what is a midpoint reversal midpoint
reversal that is you'll see and we're
talking classically constructed works
but often what you see is this let's say
it's a dramatic piece you're using
dramatic tension so them under the first
act is you have main character wants the
the money that they're owed and the end
of the second act you're going to get
some kind of resolution of that if if
you go with the idea that the they're
going to get it in the end the
resolution of a movie you forget it
the end of the second act is often the
point where it doesn't look like they're
going to get it okay
the midpoint is usually the mirror
opposite looks like they are going to
get it it's just a game of contrasts
that the character tries different
things and you see possible glimpses of
outcome now you get a lean on Toy Story
this is a moment when there a pizza
planet and it looks like they're gonna
get home because okay we're gonna jump
in this stroller and we're out of here
and that's the closest thing yet it
looks like that could be it and then
though the movies gonna be over and then
that's exactly the moment when it goes
the other way and he gets caught by Sid
and they wind up in this horrible
torture chamber so that that's that's an
example but it's a an opportunity to
give us a glimpse of how that what the
ending could be like sometimes it's like
if it's a tragedy it could be the high
point you know in classic drama like
19th century that would be the point
where the first half is character doing
stuff the second half of the play is
stuff happening to the character
whatever they started doing starts
coming back on them in a tragedy it
could be the high point is the high
point you know the mid point is the high
point it's the place where in going back
to Cuckoo's Nest that there looks like
he says I'm out of here 98 days I've
succeeded I don't have to
it go back to the prison and so it looks
like he won that's his objective is I
don't want to work and I want to go back
to prison and then he finds out no yours
here forever now you're not in prison
anymore you're here forever and that
changes the dynamics so
oh and Sunset Boulevard he he makes a
decision I'm leaving I'm leaving her he
gets trapped in this life with this
woman at this mansion is he's totally
dependent on her he finally makes a
decision I'm leaving I can't stand this
anymore and he goes out and leaves this
mansion and he goes to a party with all
his friends and he's having a good time
and what happens he gets a call and it's
the woman that he was with has tried to
commit suicide now he's got to go back
so he gets we get this moment where of a
possible outcome he's gonna he gets away
and then it goes down as a tragedy so
that's the high point and it travels
down it's it's just mid points an
opportunity to use contrast in cinema
contrast works we if the outcome is
positive it could be if the second act
and the second act is negative it could
be positive vice-versa tragedy it works
a different way some people use it as
when they have the idea of the second
act being broken into or act 3 and 4 and
that wait 2 and 3 is the middle it could
be a place where tension changes and if
you're observing sequences that's the
point where you'll have a break between
two sequences but it's certainly a place
when you're developing a story to look
for the possibilities of how the story
could plausibly end and then you're in
your god you can make it not end there
but look at what the possibilities are
you could also use it as a break point
where you can make a whole new movie
this is shop around the corner we're in
the midpoint I told you the story
neither character knows
that they're in love with the other they
think they hate each other but they're
in love with somebody else
and it's a midpoint one of them figures
it out so the first part of the story is
people in a shop the second part of the
story is people in a shop two of them
are in love and they don't know it okay
the next story we see that's two stories
the next story we see is that same
situation but one of them does know now
what happens and then finally the ending
is both know so it's a way okay you've
got this premise how are you gonna
explore all the different ways that it
could they could go and all the scenes
you could come get out of this the
apartment Billy Wilder is just it's
worth looking at all his movies because
he's a new hot it's a textbook of
screenwriting but the apartment is the
the middle of the story
it's again a suicide attempt where this
person is pursuing this woman and he is
very upset because he finds out she's
somebody else and then the second half
of that second act is about nurturing
that woman back to health after a
suicide attempt so it it's a situation
that we get a glimpse of his life
without her in the middle and then end
of the second act we get a glimpse of
him with success without her and then
the third act is the resolution as he
gets her but he doesn't have the job so
it's three very contrasting moments but
again midpoint some people will say Act
one then act to a and act to be divided
it that way
and you have kind of a subtle change in
the what the tension is in the subject
matter in the two halves second act so
midpoint well so midpoint reversal it
depends it could be depending on how you
redefine it if it's Toy Story the
reversal insidee winds up it SIDS house
that's right in the middle of the story
rather than it's a reversal from what
his hope is
reversal of fortune that kind of thing
so is there anything you want your
students to know before they begin
writing a screenplay before they begin
writing a screenplay what they should
know there anything they should know
before writing a screenplay yeah I guess
there is what am i passionate enough
about this project to spend six months
on it they might do I really care that
much because it's gonna be tough
sledding at some point and in fact my my
old mentor had a couple of suggestions I
forget if I shared these there yes a
couple of interesting suggestions for
how to deal with when the going gets
really rough he said that what you do
when you get your inspiration for this
script and it's gonna be the greatest
script you ever anybody ever wrote then
what you do is you type it out on a
piece of paper type it out we don't do
that write it out on a computer and then
print it out later what the reviews are
gonna be what your speech is gonna be at
the Academy Award what historians are
gonna say about this script and how
great it is you put all that on a piece
of paper and you seal it an envelope you
put it away somewhere carefully and then
when you're writing it and you're in the
middle of it and everything sucks
everything is like I've ever seen you
write taste like yesterday's oatmeal you
know it doesn't work and you're and you
say I'm done I'm giving up you said
that's when you reach for your envelope
because it reconnects you with what that
initial inspiration was now in my
experience doing that I never had to
reach I was always like what if that
fails I better not reach for it I'll
keep going
but knowing it's there helped you know
this is not working so before they begin
are they passionate enough about the
subject matter to whether the pain
that's going to cause to to do it to dry
it yeah I like that idea so so right
when you're like there's a spark and
you're just so into it you're writing
not the script you're writing or
your acceptance speech you're up there
you're in your dress or your talks
whatever and right you're thanking
everyone and and how it's changed the
course of culture whatever you upset
about yes and and then you keep that
there Wow interesting yeah it's it's an
interesting tool you also said don't
write to the edge when you're writing a
scenes you don't if you got the idea of
how they scene will end don't finish it
stop and make a few notes about how are
you gonna finish it and then that way
when you pick up the next day you're not
starting over again you're like oh
that's where I was and you can pick up
where you left off so never write all
the way to where you would no longer
have any more ideas stop just before
then and then keep plowing ahead than
the next time so that's something I do
all the time
just to make sure that I always know
what's what's coming next and he said
don't write if you're not excited get
whatever your technique is whether it's
listening to music or getting up and
pacing around the room but get excited
about what you're doing because of that
will show through what you're doing the
passion comes through so when the
student does begin the screenplay how
should they start how should they start
I could tell you how I start because I
don't they'll have their own approaches
if they if they're beginning of
screenplay if they have a treatment
already then obviously they just they
should just pour it on the page what are
they seeing hallucinate what it is it
and don't set aside the critical element
you know is it this or is it
accomplishing is it this tool or that
and forget all that just pour it on the
page and follow this and hallucinate
what is happening write down imagine it
and write down what it is that that's
how they begin when I'm writing a draft
of a script I don't format it in any way
it's just the dialogue just a long list
of the dialogue
it's just so that it'll keep flowing and
it's not it's just a lot of the keys to
make it feel like it's fully alive and
people don't live with properly format
and dialogue they just things flow and
so when they're just starting out it's
just part on the page loosen 8 try to
have fun with it be excited about it
listen to me music makes all the
difference you know come up with the
right score that gets you excited and
and when I say hallucinate imagine it
imagine what the audience is gonna
experience have the fun that they're
gonna have with it there's this idea of
imagination in a screenplay
in order to do screenwriting you gotta
have imagination but most people think
that means the imagination involved in
coming up with an interesting character
an interesting story that's true but
that's only part of it there's really
three parts I think that imagination
comes into play the second part is
coming up with imaginative solutions to
story problems because you'll run into
those you'll come in yo you write your
draft and then somebody will say well
this it doesn't work from page 30 on
because of that and you don't want to
throw out 90 pages so you say well why
isn't it working
oh I bet we can solve it this way we go
this way and then that'll take care of
that problem and sometimes the it can be
something very simple but being
imaginative about solving these problems
then the third part is being able to
constantly imagine that you are the
audience that hasn't seen it before that
you're watching it for the first time
and keeping track of that what are we
seeing what one of my expectations is
what am i afraid of that that part of it
and that's fun you know you are do you
you're inspired to make movies because
you are thrilled by movies so we'd be
that let that thrill happen while you're
writing it this is exciting what you're
doing so should a writer be more dialed
in to what the audience is thinking or
what that character I mean what what if
I'm so in the mindset of the character
that I'm
writing about the protagonist how am i
able to remove myself and imagine the
audience well if you can get so into the
character that you lose track of what's
going on that's great and you could
always fix it in the rewrite that's what
rewrites are for you've got a character
who is fully alive and immersed and
doing things and then you you give it to
someone or you reread it and something
is you either confusing or it's lost its
thread or this or that then you can
always go back and construct it in an
interesting way but getting the
characters that come fully alive is it's
a great accomplishment that will help
you um say this this phenomena that the
writers do talk about and I've seen it
and even again in 19th century writings
about theatre this experience that the
character I didn't really write that the
character wrote it the characters really
alive and they did that now I've had
that experience and other writers when
it's good that's what it feels like I
just I'm just the witness who writes
down what they're saying I don't know
where it came from
and it comes from somewhere inside but
so at some point that's more the
critical side but still it's fun to
imagine you're the audience and
wondering and and being involved in
experiencing this and watching that
character do these things and wondering
how they're gonna deal with the next
crisis whatever it might be what screen
writing skills are hard to learn but
will pay off later down the line and pay
dividends screen what'll make you rich
let me tell you actually in the last
chapter of that new book I said how
George did it you know this was an I did
an analysis of Star Wars it said the
title of chapter is how George did it or
can I make four billion dollars - or
something does but I did I put an
asterisk results not guaranteed that's
good I didn't wanna get sued
okay what skills are hardest to learn
and will pay off later and not
necessarily monetarily but just pay off
later in terms of your artistic
abilities what's wrong with that yeah
that's right
hey man it's about the art yeah about
doing an old saying I skill that's hard
maybe it's just taking notes
I don't know sorry I'm energetic Oh
taking notes in terms of people giving
you notes yeah I don't know me I mean is
that sort of a its own skill
well that that involves listening in two
ways one is well there's a difference
between analysis and response someone
who gives you notes or not is often
giving you a response well I didn't work
for me and then you have to take that
and filter it through analysis and
figure out why isn't it and that that
certainly takes skill but I think the
skill that's really it's learning I
think how to flesh out a character I
think that takes longer for most some
the start with character right away but
to get us in the to develop techniques
by which you get a sense of who a
character is and really portray them in
a vivid way that's the skill that pays
off because because your your right not
writing actually you're not writing
characters you're writing roles you're
writing the role for an actor and so if
that character is really exciting it's
an act it's a role that an actor would
want to play and that that's very
helpful yeah I can be that person you
know no that would be a challenging role
for me to play so - I think that takes
life experience and to learn about
people that so it takes longer and there
are techniques that that you can learn
there are if you have an opportunity to
take an acting class and see the
exercises that that actors do and they
are all about what would this character
do in this situation and what are the
choices they make and what choices and
how would they express what they're
doing so I think if you can master the
creation of really memorable roles that
that's very effective payoff
what's funny is you talked about you
know trying to make the next Star Wars
franchise or whatever just listening to
the behind the scenes for carry with
Brian DePalma I think he talked about
they shared the same casting space
before Star Wars at that time so really
would be like you know what I don't want
this person but why don't you have them
and so I think one of the people kind of
had tried out for the Han Solo role or
one of them and they said actually no
all Brian DePalma said I'll take him and
so he ended up as the boyfriend I think
and Carrie so they were kind of like
sharing okay so he was in The Greatest
American Hero
he was yeah he's great yeah give me
blanking on the name but forget yeah
what what his name is
don't tell him that we forgot his name
I'm sure it's it's it's he's a great
actor but a lot of good stuff but yeah
interesting but my point is that it at
that time you know here he's they're
they're they're sharing this casting
space they don't have any idea the
implications of really both those movies
sure and you know it was quote the quote
unquote passion projects and I think
Spacek was not even the original
choice for caring she was a makeup
artist or she was a set designer and she
kept kind of pushing I want to be a part
of this project and just things they
said all right well we will we'll test
you again and that worked out I suddenly
didn't carry 676 in Star Wars and 77 is
it I know yeah I think Carrie came out
in 70 yeah really maybe early 77 mm so
that was the same time well see the
characters didn't know what the story
was gonna be about that's our human
condition they didn't know what was
ahead yeah didn't didn't necessarily
plan it to be a franchise right what is
top down construction versus bottom up
okay well these are terms that come from
constructivist psychology and the idea
is that bottom-up stimulus is where you
see something in the world and it goes
into your brain and it's stored there
and you it's a process of learning
and from the observationally
you have object recognition and
development of schemas object
recognition is obviously something that
has wings and a beak and you know
flutters like this hummingbird object
recognition um schema is like cake with
candles on it
party favors balloons birthday party
it's a conceptual framework so but you
have to learn those things and then they
become embedded in your in your memory
in your storage area top-down means that
in after that's happened when you see
something you compare the new stuff with
the schemas and the object recognition
that you already have stored up if you
compare and you come to conclusion about
what it is you're seen it's a sure way
of short handing I don't have to if I
just take a glance and see other party
streamers on the cake and ice cream I
don't have to examine the whole thing to
figure out what it is I compare it to a
stored memory say Oh birthday party
so when where that comes in in in
screenwriting is and in filmmaking
generally is that we only get incomplete
information and we piece it together
just like we pieced together the story
we piece we construct an understanding
based on the schemas in our memories so
that when and some like it hot you see
the birthday cake and party and all that
and we think day party but then a guy
comes out pops out of the top of the
machine gun and shoots everybody if
that's a schema violation you know
that's like we come to one conclusion it
turns out to be something else in that
case they let us know there was a guy
that was going to do that but in in when
you're telling a story cinematically you
can exploit the idea that you can give
incomplete in four
and audiences will construct it and
anticipate where you're going based on
schemas and then you can introduce new
information that changes our
understanding of the situation so what I
mentioned a movie top secret that used
that a lot where you have people though
that are things we've seen before a guy
on a train and out the window the
platform is going by and then we see
that it's actually the Train is standing
still the platform was being pulled you
know so we have a schema we recognize
that and then we see the what's actually
happening
I think it's violated so it's can be
used for a gag they actually with this
idea of it's been used as a gag
non-diegetic dialogue or sound like you
have a convention a schema that and it
suspense scene you're going to have
music right and the character doesn't
hear it and the characters don't hear it
it's not not part of the world of the
story but that's something we understand
if you or didn't have any knowledge of
it you might think any music is gonna
come from what you're seeing in fact I
think in the early days of sound they
did that they had Al Jolson the singing
when you're getting music it's singing
and he's doing it but in the concept of
having incidental music which derived
probably from theater from opera was
brought in and so a new concept or new
schema arises which is the what do you
call it the soundtrack music or the
incidental music and you can have a
situation where like in Blazing Saddles
the guy is riding his horse and there's
a band playing music and then he pulls
up and it's you know Count Basie and his
orchestra is out in the desert playing
so that for the when is it stranger than
fiction you know where there's voice
over dialogue about this guy
was going through a normal day and he
always brushes his teeth the same way
and the voiceover saying that and at one
point he stops it where's that coming
from
you know and so we get that that
violation of our schema and it's used in
that sense for comic effect Monty Python
did the same thing with that with swab
castle when the young man tries in the
Holy Grail he's try singing a song he's
in despair he wants his true love and
and the father comes in and says no no
music I'm not doing that not you're
doing a song that kind of thing did they
do that in the airplane movies too it
kind of played off of the same people
who did top-secret to the airplane
movies so I very likely I don't think
about examples of where well certainly
things like the jet plane making a drone
like a prop plane throughout the whole
movie you know that that's something
contrary to what our schema is and
that's it yeah I'm sure there's other
insurance from that but I'd have to look
at it again which would not be a problem
yeah I missed the one reason